hi i'm nala from quicktake in
minneapolis right now police traffic
stops have declined significantly
since the death of george floyd i'm
joined by sarah holder from bloomberg
city lab
who's reported on the story and is here
to share more on the data
and her reporting hi sarah thank you so
much for joining us today
hey great to be here awesome so sarah
can you start us
off and just tell us what exactly you
found from your reporting
yeah so along with my colleagues rachel
doddle and marie patino who are great
data journalists
we looked through uh the rate of traffic
stops in minneapolis
um traffic stops are one of the most
frequent police community
interactions nationwide the stanford
university's open policing project
estimates that about 50 000 drivers and
pedestrians are stopped each day
um for these routine stops for moving
violations like speeding tickets
um or equipment violations like a broken
taillight
um or sometimes pre-tech stops which are
stops that police make
um that are sort of intending to find
evidence of
more serious crimes um in minneapolis
uh these stops are quite frequent as i
mentioned
as they are in many other american
cities
um but since may 25th when george floyd
was killed by a police officer they're
down about 80 percent
that is quite a significant number and
you mentioned that
you know there seems to be this trend of
police disengaging disengaging after
mass protests against racial injustice
are there any other examples of this
happening across the country
do we see people or police kind of
pulling back
um their efforts or their work or the
the
are declining um when when we do have
mass protests or we
do come into incidents similar to the
death of george void
yeah i mean so it's hard to you know
draw a direct correlation between these
two events but we did see you know a
small
dip in traffic stops during coronavirus
um where fewer cars were on the road
but it was really nothing compared to
the 80 drop
as as we talked about after the killing
of george floyd and the protests across
the city
you know i wasn't able to talk to police
officers in minneapolis and they helped
with some of the data research but we
couldn't you know sit down and talk
through why um this is happening but we
are seeing you know anecdotal evidence
in minneapolis of
9-1-1 calls taking a long time to be
responded to
um police officers leaving the force
retiring early
taking medical leave um and that's
something we have seen in other american
cities
uh as well um perhaps it is you know
due to increased scrutiny over activity
perhaps it's due to shifting priorities
um perhaps it's due to being short
staffed um
and distracted um but you know more
research is really needed on
what traffic stops are still being um
conducted
uh you know even though it's an 80 drop
we saw that some of the racial
disparities in who is being stopped
have continued um so while the volume is
down some of the issues that
activists and criminal justice advocates
have highlighted um in in these
you know over policing of black and
brown communities have not appeared to
have changed us significantly and you
mentioned specifically traffic stops
what else is the data telling us
specifically
is there a historical context that we
should be aware of is our traffic stops
typically an area where police do make a
lot of arrests
yeah so i mean in minneapolis the
hennepin county public defender's office
has done a lot of work on this year over
year they find that
though minneapolis has more of a larger
white population than a black population
black drivers are stopped more
frequently than wet drivers
again year after year um and you know
these racial disparities have narrowed a
bit
as the as the overall volume of stops
have decreased um but those still appear
and you know there are several
consequences to being
stopped by police whether that's a fine
or a fee um
an arrest um you know a violent
altercation as in the case of philando
castile
um these can also be traumatizing for
people again if you're
you're stopped for no reason or for a
reason that you don't understand um
and it as the aclu says it can erode
community trust
um but at the same time you know some
traffic stops are necessary to
help curb dangerous driving um and so
it's really
i think uh a growing balance um
is is being desired from from folks on
the ground absolutely
and were there specific reasons that you
came across that people were typically
being stopped for or was it just more
general yeah so i think that's a place
where
data more data research needs to be done
but as i
as i said i guess it's mostly moving
violations
equipment violations you know suspicious
vehicles
all those might be reasons why police
might pull someone over
or those sorts of pretext stops there is
a program in minneapolis called lights
on
which was instituted after the killing
of philando castile where
if you are pulled over for a broken
taillight for example instead of getting
a ticket you can get a voucher
um to repair that violation and
hopefully stop you from getting pulled
over again
um again there can be racial disparities
in how those vouchers are
handed out um so it's not you know a
perfect solution
uh says um you know uh
advocates from the aclu um but that is
one um
one change that we've seen in the past
four years um and could
you know change the kinds of traffic
stops that we're seeing out of
minneapolis
in the years to come absolutely and
you've mentioned philando castile a
couple of times now um i just wanted to
touch on that briefly
and talk about some of the consequences
that we do see when people are stopped
by police
one that is top of mind i'm sure for all
of us right now is brianna taylor
can you speak to that a little bit what
exactly or did your research find any
any sort of consequences when we do see
over policing in community
yeah absolutely i mean i think that
that's such a
salient example of a you know a police
uh
interaction gone very wrong and i think
that that's why
you know um activists who are hoping to
reimagine policing
um cut funding to policing and invest it
in other social services have identified
traffic stops as just one area
where um police could be replaced uh in
you know these
functions by other unarmed enforcement
officers so you know in berkeley
california they voted to create a new
department of transportation
um where unarmed officers would handle
police traffic stops again you know
stopping
dangerous driving but they would never
have a gun when they are
stopping someone for speeding um and so
i think it comes from
a fear that these interactions
can lead to harmful outcomes for
communities of color and
and um people like philando castile
absolutely and with all of this
disengagement we are seeing has that had
any impact on
the conversations we've we've seen
occurring this summer
in terms of you know defunding the
police or abolishing the police
yeah i mean i think it's uh it's too
soon to tell
about a lot of the momentum that's
happening right now i know that a lot of
cities have had their budget
conversations already and have made
small cuts or small increases um and so
i think in the budget
discussions to follow there might be
more of an emphasis
on where can we invest in in you know
the department of transportation in safe
driving um
and where can we invest in in the police
and yeah i mean i think in minneapolis
especially that's a really
salient conversation because it's where
um
these recent rash of protests have
started
um because it was where george ford was
killed and so i think that they're sort
of at the forefront of these
conversations and
we'll definitely be looking at
their police department as an example of
you know how to how to do things better
absolutely absolutely and as you
mentioned this has been definitely a hot
button topic
all summer long and i'm sure we're going
to see it carry on um into
well into the rest of the year so that
leads me to my next question
in terms of police disengaging have you
seen any other reasons why
they are kind of pulling back on their
work or stepping back from their work
following all of these protests we've
seen over summer
yeah i mean it's again like it would be
great to be able to you know talk to
some
police officers from minneapolis
specifically about what their priorities
are
right now i think that perhaps
they have been pulled in different
directions perhaps
it is has been a hard year coronavirus
has
has changed police priorities a lot um
as i said too like there are you know
maybe
50 fewer officers in august as there
were at the beginning of the year
um so perhaps they're short-staffed um
and um
yeah i think i think that's a
conversation that has been
happening um among many minneapolis city
council members
um and i think that they you know have
been having community conversations
about
uh what the police um are doing
but i think it's it's good to note that
without more data
on again what um police traffic stops
have been continuing so you know that 80
percent drop like where is the
the brunt of the activity being focused
on so we don't know
um if that is you know focusing on these
dangerous driving incidents
or if it is um focusing on speeding or
or what um and so that would be really
helpful to know
as well and thank you so much for
bringing us back to that number that 80
drop which is such a significant
decrease
um can you speak to that number a little
bit have we ever seen a drop like this
before
uh so not uh not to my knowledge again
like
coronavirus changes everything but at
the same time
um the dip that we saw in march and
april
is just so small compared to the dip
that we saw in
in may and in june and you know
continuing through the summer
um so i mean to put that number in
context um
police were making about 351 traffic
stops a week
uh before may 25th and now they're
making about 70 a week
so um it's a it's just a really really
stark figure and and um
it'll be interesting to to learn more
about the why which i think
you know you're getting at um right now
and i would love to learn more about
that too
absolutely and that is quite a change i
think from going to almost 400 to about
70 a week that that is definitely quite
a change
um and that leads me to my next question
is there anything that
you reported on or that maybe you found
out in your research that didn't make it
into your article
yeah i mean i've been doing some
reporting on these calls to defund or to
reimagine policing in minneapolis the
city council had
you know agreed to pursue a plan to
create an office of violent prevention
and to disband the police department as
it exists right now and
to you know recreate uh and and
reimagine what
it looks like um and i think that they
sort of had the boldest plan for doing
so
um but because of some bureaucratic
issues some
um some uh technicalities with the
city's charter or their constitution
they were not able to pursue that plan
um that
that many city council members were um
backing
um so i think that you know this
disengagement or this pullback
um is coming across a backdrop of just a
lot of conversations about where
policing goes next in minneapolis and i
think
um it'll be interesting to see where
this office of violent prevention
violence prevention goes um and how
smaller reforms might trickle into
the minneapolis police department in the
months to come
absolutely absolutely and what exactly
was your intent in seeking out this
information
what was your goal when you first
started reporting on this story and
did you kind of reach that end goal or
did you find out what you were seeking
that's a that's a really good question i
think often with these data projects you
kind of go in looking for as much
information as you can get and
hope the data can you know lead you
somewhere i think we were just really
interested in traffic stops because they
are
this just very frequent
uh space of interaction that you don't
think about you know it's not a violent
crime
necessarily it's sort of just a routine
um going about your day might be stopped
by a police officer
on the side of the road and as we've
talked about it can lead to
pretty intense consequences um so we're
just interested
in examining the behavior of police in
this realm
um also because this is a space where
there have been all these proposals to
um
you know break up those duties and so i
guess we were trying to figure out
how police spend their time um and
whether anything
has changed um since the the death of
george floyd and the
protests that have happened after and we
did find that you know
uh things had changed quite a bit i
guess the next question that we would
want to
keep pulling data to answer is for how
long
whether traffic stops will bounce back
up to
pre-may 25th levels and when that will
happen
um and then as you rightly pointed out
like
what's happening in other cities um and
and is this
number being reflected nationwide and i
think that's such a good point
for you to make whether this will be the
same change or whether we'll kind of see
these numbers climb back
up to nearly 400 stops a week again or
more
um once we kind of have come out of the
the direct aftermath of most of these
protests
um so thank you so much i think this is
a great place for us to stop
thank you so much for joining us today
sarah i think this is such an important
conversation for us to continue to have
and to
engage with absolutely thank you so much
for having me this was great
awesome take care and be sure to follow
quick take
for all your news updates
you